congratulations on this movie you both
are so phenomenal in this i thought
about this movie a lot after it was done
i can stop talking about it with my
sister your cat just got on the screen
that's so cute
how much could you relate to a character
like ruth who would do anything to
protect her younger sister who she
essentially raised as her own
it's her child you know what what is it
to parents
what is it um what does it apparent when
the cards that you're dealt with poverty
from the moment that you arrived on this
planet what is it apparent when your
sacrifice will never have a movie made
about it or seen as valiant or
you'll get a good job or you're even
seen for that matter and
the more i
talk to incredible human beings that
were in the prison system incredible
human beings that had been released from
the prison system and you heard their
stories of
the moment they arrived on this planet
they all had similar themes
and it's resources it's poverty
it is um the lack of eyes on you seeing
you as valuable
how do you survive how do you get up
every day and see value within yourself
if the rest of the world society is
saying you have none
yeah absolutely and you know obviously
we see the journey that ruth goes
through um rob i loved you in this so
much you know you as ruth's parole
officer you obviously want her to
succeed after she gets out of prison but
you're tough on her um what was it like
playing that dynamic with sandra
uh in between wanting to hug and hold
sandra in between every take and fall in
love with her because of the way she
embodied ruth slater like day in and day
out and carried that emotional pain and
you can see it on her face and then to
be responsible with producing the film
at the same time it was like wow this is
superwoman in the flesh you know
uh that was the hardest part to not just
want to like go and just hug her and say
oh it's okay girl it's okay
you know but to understand that it was
very important for me to play that fine
line of like therapist in a way
to give her the gems to keep her from
re-entering back into the prison system
wanting to keep my recidivism rate low
uh being the the male voice in the in
the project uh
a place where she can come that was safe
but yet
not too
soft at the same time like i just shared
before how the eagle builds the uh nests
and keeps the thorns purposely so when
the eagle baby eagle gets too big to
just lounge around they won't because
they'll get pricked out and they'll have
to jump out and fly yeah you know so
yeah that kind of thing
well i loved the dynamic in this um
sandra before i let you go we're doing a
big special on betty white with it being
her 100th birthday
early next year i want to know from you
obviously she's your friend you worked
with her on the proposal what do you and
the rest of the world love about betty
you know she had such gratitude for what
she had you know i i would keep looking
at the ring she had on her finger that
was given to her by the love of her life
passed away um and how she spoke about
that time with him they built this house
and they built it and he passed away
shortly after it was built and just she
described a time when they were sitting
there and i believe there was a
fireplace at least in my
image and i for some reason have
knitting needles on betty's lap but just
her description of being able to sit
with him in front of the fire and savor
those moments when they knew they didn't
have a lot left and how she saw her
her stepchildren by marriage and
the gratitude and the joy she had for
every single thing that she'd been
blessed with
um i thought to myself if i could have
half of her gratitude for the life that
i live i would consider myself so
blessed um
she she recounts every moment of her
life with such reverence
and it was an eye-opener for me because
she remembered everything
every detail every moment when she
recounted a story to me i felt like i
feel like thinking of that story
i was in the room with them the way that
she's able to share with you her journey
um
that's why we all love her because she
can break your heart and make you laugh
at the same time in a woman at that time
being able to be as irreverent and
groundbreaking as she was and still is
it's uh she's a maverick she's a woman
who um
she's changed a lot for me uh and blazed
a path for me
and i'm not blind to it
i'm not blind to it
i love that thank you so much for that
answer that was so amazing well
congratulations on this movie robin
sandra wow very powerful film thanks so
much thank you